What's up?
I'm excited.
I just published a Chrome extension for the first time, and it's live for free on Chrome,
and it replaces Loom absolutely free and does everything that Loom does absolutely free
with no ties to the subscription.
So go download this if you use Loom or your recording videos or your recording screen
shares, does everything Loom does absolutely free.
So go download it, I'm going to show you a demo of that because it's live, but we're
actually looking at the app if you want to download the GitHub and go get the app, but
we're going to demo the extension because you don't even have to do the GitHub.
I know that sounds way too technical.
So we're not going to worry about all that technical stuff, and we're just going to worry
about the simple stuff.
So a link should be down below, and it's called my pip cam, and this is exactly what it does.
I'm going to go ahead and remove it so we can go through the install process together.
All right, so as soon as you click the link, you should open it in Chrome.
This is a Chrome extension, so don't have to be on any certain OS as long as you're using
Chrome, and you can install this.
Add to Chrome.
We're going to go ahead and add this extension.
It's telling you that it could read the screen, view the screen.
Once we have it added, I'm going to click it here, and I got all kinds of extensions.
There it is, I'm going to pin it, so it shows up in my little bar here, but now that I have
it pinned, this is what it does, just like you would expect Loom, and then I can start
the recording.
I'm going to add effects to that, and then when they're all set and done and all these
videos are recorded, they're going to go to your library, and in this library, I'm going
to be able to connect it to Google Drive, and then I'm going to be able to pick a local
folder as well, so I'm going to go ahead and pick this folder, and when I pick my local
folder, it's going to ask me, are you sure you want to allow this app to edit your folders,
because we are putting videos in, and taking videos out of that folder.
Do we want to keep that setting, absolutely, and then it's going to look just like your
Loom dashboard, so you can see all your recorded videos, you can see which ones I've uploaded
to the Google Drive, which ones are still here locally, and then I can see the activity,
one person has viewed this, I have a sharing link, now that it's on the drive, I can hit
share, get that link, go over here, and somebody can go watch my video, and then I get notified
when they've watched it, all the features of Loom without having a Loom subscription just
by installing this free plugin that I've built for you, so go download it, get any questions,
feel free to hit me up, but I'm excited about this, hope you guys are, hope you guys put
it to use, and stay tuned for more, oh, be sure to follow, follow if you download it,
I deserve a follow, right, thank you.